[Music]
oh man it's been
tough
yeah all right Rose hi Rose where are
you from originally I'm born and raised
in Los Angeles California tell me about
your your
family
well I am
the second child of my mother's only
child of my dad's they both work in the
television industry when they were
working and I guess that's how they
met and uh they both had an a a pension
for loving cocaine so that kind of
formed like Voltron you know so that's
what they did and um my mom had a
son prior to me from her first husband
early on he was 11 years older than me
my brother is and um um then my I'm my
mom and dad's only child yeah and they
divorced they separated when I was
four um among some really intense
fighting from what I can recall like I
have it's weird how you can remember
like certain core memories that aren't
even that significant in nature but they
just are kind of etched into your even
at a young age yeah oh my God you
wouldn't even people say you can't
remember things like that far back I
remember things certain traumatic events
from like age of three honestly um but
we'll get to that I guess how would you
describe your childhood in
general tra
traumatic um I didn't really have much
of a childhood cuz I had
to I was sexualized very early on and I
had to kind
of um grow up too fast who who did that
to you my maternal
grandfather and my mom's other child my
half
brother
yeah kind of changes your life forever
doesn't it yeah it took me a a long long
time I'm I'm
43 um it took me a long time to kind of
um God it's such a crazy story dude it's
so
crazy of how it all happen but okay
so my mom's son is 11 years older than
me and
um he started touching me when I was
three and so did I think the first
person to touch me though is my mom's
dad my grandfather he was a [__]
Wicked man just evil
Wicked um and I I remember it so vividly
it was Easter Sunday
I I was wearing my Easter dress I
remember it clear as day I don't know
how I remember something so early on but
look I felt
asleep on their couch after like an
hunting for eggs or something and uh I
woke up to being
touched and I just kind of didn't really
I kept my eyes shut because I was really
scared I remember and
um I don't really remember too many like
of the episodes after that
from that early on but that one kind of
stuck out in my brain
um and you know it's weird unbeknownst
to each other my brother also started
touching me around the same time you
know so it was kind of simultaneous in
nature but unbeknownst to each other and
I honestly believe that my grandfather
touched my brother too because it's a
it's a learned behavior you know I mean
like you don't just go out and start
molesting unless I mean I'm sure maybe
somebody does but like not usually it's
usually learned behavior um so I feel
like that's why it was a lot easier for
me
to eventually forgive my brother or it
runs in the family yeah not yeah well
that stopped with
me um but yeah so yeah that my childhood
was you know really rather traumatic
Pepper with with some really fun cool
stuff peppered in what kind of teenager
were you I was a nightmare I was a
nightmare I went to six different high
schools
um three of which were in the valley and
then um two on the West Side three on
the west side and in the end because I'd
gone to so many schools I messed up my
transcripts so much uh like a week
before actual graduation they told me
that I didn't have enough credits and I
was just like [__] this at that point I
was already going to Raves it was was
like the late 90s I was like I'm going
to the desert in the middle of nowhere
with people that I don't know and having
a great time instead so and I was a
nanny so I didn't even really worry
about any of that like I they didn't
care if I had a high school diploma yeah
they asked but like they're not really
checking you know like if I have a
diploma doesn't really matter do you
Vibe with the kid are you a safe
person you know
um I'm really good with kids it's kind
of weird like they all love me
do you have kids of your own I have one
son he's
14 he's amazing um you were there to
raise
him
yes um I've been
there you know since he was born and the
only time that I wasn't was when I was
pretty messed up and being making
selfish choices you know what I mean um
choosing
you
know substance use above him or a guy
above or love love you know what I mean
like and because of that like I feel
like I missed I missed some
stuff and when he really needed
me cuz
um I kid's been through it you know he
lost his
dad early on
how did he lose his
dad uh how what now how did he lose his
father oh he uh he it was an overdose an
accidental
overdose
um and
uh it was really sudden and hard to
explain to him at the time it was really
close to his birthday at the time he was
there when it
happened you know and um having to come
back from where I was
at and tell him that news because they
didn't want to tell him it was just so
heartbreaking because he just didn't
understand at first he's like okay so
all right but when am I going to am I
going to see my dad again when am I
going to see my dad again like baby
you're not going to see your dad
again it's really tough be a hard
conversation to have it is and like I
never thought I would have to have that
conversation with him like I know people
that have died and stuff like that but I
never thought it would hit that close to
home
um yeah so that's been tough and as he's
gotten older the sadness has kind of
gave way to anger and acting out and um
me being kind of passive and weak
because I have you know I feel guilty I
feel you know were you using over
compensate were you using as well uh not
the same
thing no he he liked downers and I liked
uppers yeah I liked past how long were
you using uh I was using for a long time
and I maintained um what I thought I
maintained an addiction for 10 years
with the route of ingestion that I was
having it this Crystal or crank Crystal
I thought I don't think they make crank
anymore do they no Crystal or crank oh
CRA oh no not crack I've never done
crack and I was so surprised when so
many of my like normal friends are just
like oh yeah I've tried crack I'm like
what what are you talking about you just
casually tried crack one time like
that's so weird they're kind of like one
or the other if you're doers crack I
just I'm good um you know what's weird
is that I never really messed with
Crystal until I moved back here from
Philly and
um after I had my kid and it was like a
year and a half after I had him and a
friend of mine was like here try this I
was like okay seems like a really
brilliant idea to just start up a new
drug habit of 31 years old
genius so um I maintained it by smoking
it for a minute for a couple years and
then
um I went to a rehab and while I was in
a rehab one of my bones was like oh my
my boyfriend's in jail he's in there
with a guy who wants a pen pal I was
like all right I've never done that I
can cross that off a bucket list you
know all right how to jail pen pal in
life cool chucked off that kind of
snowballed
into God people guys that are in jail
know how to sweet talk girls like it is
just and it is just so crazy how they
are just so V you while they're in jail
why is so easy to fall into that kind oh
God and
then you know oh here I am being an
idiot iding all over the the place like
so dumb cuz they're not in the cuz they
have no options well but yeah but you're
and I'm right there but but you're not
pressured into a relationship because
he's he's in prison exactly well that's
way easier for me it's you know no
commitment stay there St
right yeah so but here's the thing is
that he did get
out he was only in county jail and he
went to a program that was right near
mine and
long story short I left my program early
the next day he left his
program and like two idiots in the night
we decided to join forces form like vron
and
uh that led to
probably the darkest most I can't even
say that it's a lot of [__] up shit's
happened in my later years in life one
of the most [__] up things
ever yeah it was
crazy when you were young did you have
dreams of doing something with your life
I did but I always was kind of
um I always felt kind of up until High
School like a like a follower not so
much a leader like I really cared about
everybody liking me I was bullied a lot
in school
um my kid has a total opposite School
experience so I'm really happy about
that like he's one of the more popular
kids in school and I'm just like oh
thank God that he didn't have to go
through like the same experience because
it was so bad that I knew how to like
Hustle the nurse in order to get home to
to have a fever to go home like the
whole the routine was you give me the
thermometer have a stomach ache they'll
give you a thermometer it's one of those
flat ones and so I knew that if I said I
had to go to the bathroom it would walk
by a coffee maker coffee Maker's hot
press that sucker against there for just
enough time it'll read high you can go
home right like the caveat to that
is I knew the person 99% of the time who
was going to be picking me up was going
to meet my
grandfather usually so something had to
be really bad in school for me to like
weigh the options like getting molested
staying in school and getting bullied
I'm going to choose getting molested
probably like it was pretty [__]
up
um and
uh
so
yeah that's what it
was and how many years were you using 13
okay yeah so then back to that story
sorry I see I ADHD and I squirel off I'm
sorry um so we we met up and uh went
decided it would be a good idea to live
out of my car and Ventura for whatever
reason that seemed like a brilliant idea
so that's why
like God okay so he I swear I would
never use needles especially after my
son's father
died that way but um I let that man
stick a needle in me for the first time
and it was the most amazing amazing
worst [__] thing I've ever done in my
life I mean yeah that's the only way I
can describe it the most amazing worst
[__] thing you've ever
done yeah and it was over from there
like nothing makes you lose everything
quicker than [__] banging meth like
that's just here just throw it in the
garbage right now cuz you're not going
to have it for very long it's going to
be gone and my parents thank God
rightfully so they decided to take
guardianship
temporary um guardianship of my son and
at the time I was really mad because I
felt betrayed but like they're just
doing what they needed to do to protect
them you know like and thank God for
them cuz he could have been in foster
care and if they you know what I mean
like could have been all bad
so I'm thankful for that but it got bad
before it got
better yeah
what do you think was your lowest
point slamming meth in the Ventura River
pot and getting the [__] kicked out of
me by a [__] douchebag like what what
am I
doing yeah that's probably the
lowest yeah I realized like okay this
has got to change he almost killed me
one time like he I he would flip out out
of nowhere this was the guy from prison
yeah yeah that was the the pen pal
bucket list dude pen pal yeah
genius idea of mine um yeah he would he
would do that he would slam meth and he
would get like Charles Manson eyes like
legit Manson eyes it was terrifying and
um he would just beat the [__] out of me
and I would just allow it like so unlike
me cuz it's so not like me so like if
you hear the rest of like so many layers
I'm not the one to put up with that [__]
like that's just all my friends were
just like mind boggled what the [__] did
you do what you let somebody hit you
like that's
crazy yeah so uh it was that and I got
out when he almost killed me that night
and I went straight to a rehab my second
rehab and I've
been yeah but you you somehow climbed
out of that I
did I had
to surrender you know
I guess I still don't get it I don't
know people say that they get it and
like I don't know if anybody ever really
gets it you know like I think everybody
still kind of questions themselves a
little bit at least even if they have it
all
together oh you you went to a
rehab um I I did go to the other rehab
but what really worked for me the best
was sober living because I had to kind
of like you know the rehabs I went to
were state they took medical or whatever
the state
insurances and um when I had to start
paying for my own recovery like I had to
pay to be in the sober living and once I
had to start it came out of my pocket
and stuff I started taking it more
seriously I feel like it was kind of
weird what's your biggest
regret oh
jeez hurting people by being selfish
and self-
serving betray like betraying people's
trust
yeah emotionally what kind of things
have
you like it's been a year 2023 sucked
bad and I'm so glad to kick its mangy
ass to the curb it was horrible
depression or just a lot of like
a lot of things a lot of events
happening that kind of like was the
universe being tired of gently trying to
trying to gently tell me hey this isn't
for you so I had to learn some painful
life lessons and and it was hard but
growth is painful sometimes you know
so it is what it is I just have to kind
of roll with
it so like okay last
year oh my
goodness last year I got I was in a
relationship that ended after two years
because it was just so
toxic I think maybe I'm the
problem I think I might be um I think I
might have borderline person I like I'm
not diagnosed with BPD but I am
diagnosed with like
ADHD severe depression
PTSD and that's it I think yeah but with
a a childhood like yours it's I I'm like
starting to notice a lot of borderline
personality
disorder
attributes and that makes me a little
nervous
like but
yeah I get a little nervous okay so last
year um I had a boyfriend and we were
together for like two years we just
didn't work out but he was super toxic
and wouldn't leave the house and the
cops were called a lot and
I ended up they ended up trying to evict
me but they did it really illegally and
I was like no you're not going to go
you're not I'm not going down without a
fight so I fought them I fought them and
I figured it out and basically when it
was time for our day in court the lawyer
last minute came up to me was like okay
well what do you want what are your
terms and I was like I want the same
amount that that you charged me to get
into this place and I want to stay until
the end of the year and so that's I was
out at 11:30 on December
31st and uh got the
money but now I'm like stuck in limbo
like my kids living back with my parents
and um you know that's great and all but
the thought of going back there makes me
want to gouge my eyes out so I mostly
sleep in my car um and I've been looking
for a two bedroom for him and
I but it's kind of difficult like I I
work in Santa Monica so he can go to
that school because of where I work but
I would like to find a place near there
so I'm not driving all crazy but it's
hard man it's crazy hard to find a place
and they want you to make like something
like five times the amount per month
like what am I Hugh Hefner like who has
that kind of money and is renting
apartments you know like who I don't I
don't get it but whatever I'll find it
I'll make it happen I always
do
um yeah so the eviction didn't go
through but it was attempted oh and also
my car got repossessed but I got another
one
so
yeah what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life always be
teachable yeah I'm learn how to fight
fair because sometimes I still don't
know how to fight fair I
a lot of times it's like
a it's almost like an instinctual
reaction of like I'm constantly in a
state of fight or flight or or or freeze
you know so when I feel like I'm backed
into a corner I [__] I I fight like
my life depends on it and it doesn't
always like I don't need to fight that
hard every time and I go straight for
the jugular sometimes but I've come a
long way I used to be very antagonistic
and I've come a long way so
so give myself
Grace all right Rose thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you I'm
glad you're doing better yeah I'm trying
all right thank you
thanks